Lately it’s been 3 to 4 hours.
Not having a paper changes everything.
Who's going to want to wake up at 3:30 in the morning?
I've got a full-time job and I volunteer in the morning.
Before work, I drop the refugees at the airport
and do this over again every day.
Monday to Sunday.
Just barely woke up from a nap.
I'm going to work right now.
I live in Juárez, but I cross every day because
I'm studying my major of journalism
in the University of Texas at El Paso.
If President Trump did decide to close the border,
I think it would affect a lot this community.
I'm not going to be able to finish my studies.
I usually drive every day back and forth to go to school.
There's more migrants and
with President Trump saying that he was going to close the border
and everything being like uncertain ...
and then when he started taking
some of the CBPs away for the lines,
that's when we really started to see a difference.
We’re at the bridge.
I’m doing the line to cross to El Paso.
Lately it’s been 3 to 4 hours.
Two hours.
The officers that work here at the border,
they’re being transferred to other parts of the country.
Suddenly we see this change in the border.
We basically receive a text from ICE
letting us know how many refugees are going to be released.
Like today they were released 721.
We receive daily 60 refugees.
They're either sick due to the fact that
they're in a place that is kind of cold,
running fevers, a cold, or they have stomach problems.
From Guatemala, Honduras, El Salvador ...
people that they come here to our church with
legal documents from immigration. Where they've been through
a process to make sure that they're not criminals,
for they could come into the states temporarily,
for they could each their family members.
Currently I'm working for Borderzine.
Borderzine allows you to do stories either in Spanish or in English.
We get to see like both sides of the border.
I've been here living 20, 21 years and
I've never seen so many immigrants coming.
A lot of people here in the community, especially from Juárez,
are little bit more aggressive toward the immigrants
because they're disrupting the city
because we don't have the infrastructure to kind of
support the amount of people that's coming in.
I think that when someone like migrates,
there needs to be something really bad happening back home
because of the travel they do.
They don't have water, there's a load of heat.
You need to walk for days, for weeks, for months.
Not having a paper changes everything.
A sock.
Currently in the El Paso sector,
we are averaging approximately
700 individuals being detained on a daily basis.
Oh, look!
Did they walk up to you?
They just crossed and turned themselves
in to this Border Patrol agent.
Father, daughter, father, son.
Our facilities, Border Patrol, we were never built
to house family units as we're seeing now.
So it's a huge challenge for us,
not only as in our facilities, but as far as
the agents and the supplies and the care.
My name is Cynthia Pompa and
I work as the advocacy manager at the Border Rights Center.
We simply walk across to Juárez, to Mexico
and observe what is happening.
Are there migrants or asylum seekers arriving
and are being told to turn away?
Who is telling them? What are they being told?
This is a new stretch of the border wall
that was funded during the Trump administration.
A young migrant girl showed up
to present herself at a port of entry
and was told by a CBP official that she needed to go back
and find a Mexican agent, and get herself on a list.
She was really confused and lost.
I saw a young boy who showed up to request asylum.
What is unlawful is how CBP is standing
in the middle of the international bridges,
right on the international line, and turning away asylum seekers.
I want to help the people out
because the things that I see, things that I hear from them
is like, ah, I don't like it.
They're going to different places.
All depends. They go to Miami, New York, Boston, Kansas City, Dallas ...
all depends, you know, where the family lives.
I dunno when the job will end.
I'll be there until it finishes, you know?
And to be honest, I don't know what's the day.
It could take a year, two years, I'm not sure.